I'm inside one of the engine down oil
tanks an old oil storage facility near
inverness in Scotland
this tank is 237 metres long and it's
not meant for humans when it was in use
by the Royal Navy all this colossal
space would have been filled with fuel
oil with these oil tanks the Royal Navy
accidentally created the greatest
reverberation chamber in the world flat
surfaces enclosed by solid rock and a
chamber big enough that sound takes a
whole second or more to go off the far
wall and bounce back but still now
enough that you get lots of
reverberation from all the cloak
surfaces as well the construction
started 1938 and it carried on right
through the beginning of the war up to
around about 1943 the Admiralty had
decided that they required bomb-proof
storage for their oil so they said about
building a number of our tanks across
Britain and this engine vein is one of
them the construction required sex tanks
to be built the entire complex could
easily contain a hundred thousand tons
of fuel alarm but one single wrong Navy
battleship could drink five thousand
tons so a kid go very very quickly it is
a truly amazing chamber of sound a
Cathedral of oil the Cathedral of st. so
now I'm going to shut up for a bit
Preston here is gonna fire a starting
pistol a very very loud bang on the
screen is a visual display of that sound
different frequencies will reverberate
for different amounts of time so you
will see that and hear that and as it
gets quieter we will turn up the level
on the microphone so it's easier for you
to hear right everyone ready
[Music]
thank you for the battlin group for
lightness into the tunnels to Alan Alan
and Preston for our help with everything
here to Matt Wright who is behind the
camera and who has had some musical
experiences over on his channel go Fred